where do you start with the video is
that is that where we start here is been
where you start that's a really good
question to start with so when the game
making a game is specific video the
first thing that I always research is
what engine is the game using because
there's a lot of standardization in the
industry well it's very common for most
of the big games that are coming out to
be on five or six major engines
especially because up keeping an engine
a custom engine has become such an
expensive task that most studious just
license some other engine to to use and
often that means that if there's a
moving or modifying community if there's
a community of people who are examining
previous games of the same engine
there's a lot of things that you can
learn from that that you can use even in
older versions of the engine very often
when a new game comes out which is the
first game in a new version of an engine
the first thing that I will do is like
research developer documentation for the
previous version of the engine because
they tend to be a lot of things that
still cross over
additionally a good number of PC games
store the variables that the game uses
to set up its graphics in a series of
files if you are lucky and these files
are user reachable and that means that
you can play around with them most
engines have a dev console like the
line-x terminal like any console that
you would think most of the time is not
user reachable sometimes it is jin-joo
just have to press the right letter and
it comes out in older games
it used to be always reachable but it
sadly it's become a less common thing
and from there it's a matter of
experimenting ok like let me let me let
me find a very specific example
frostbite which is the engine used by
the battlefield games battlefield games
still allow user access to the console
so a new battlefield games comes out
first thing I do is I know there's a
variable that you can add to the launch
comments of the exe that enables that
developer console and I start the game
and I press the tilde button and it
opens the console and then look ok let's
see if there's autocomplete and I will
start writing things and see if it's out
of completing comments to me like like
ok if I press tab does it auto-completed
to me okay so using that I will search
if there's a command like list all list
command variables or something to see if
I can get a dump of all the things that
are inside there that I can play around
with if not then it becomes a very
painful process of going a and then
pressing tab and autocomplete and see
what comes out and like taking
screenshots and documenting all the
little variables are inside and then
from the names of the variable
experimenting trying to guess which ones
are the ones that have to do with
graphical fidelity or graphic rendering
in general and and start changing values
see if they can be changed up runtime
see if those values I can put in a
certain file and they will read them and
see what change the game a lot of it is
guesswork but once you sort of figure a
certain engine a lot of the games on the
same engine thing tend to do something
similar for Metal Gear Solid 5 that's
probably my favorite most
crowd case Metal Gear Solid 5 runs in
something they called the Fox engine and
that engine wasn't made for PC and you
can often tell when an engine wasn't
made by for PC because it has no
configuration files this all like a
black box it's all super contained but I
really really like this game and I
really wanted to make a video about it
so I was exploring what to do and I came
through the the game had a pretty big
modding community there were people
making like model swaps there were
people introducing like new weapons in
the game through BOTS and I kept telling
myself like ok but how did they figure
this out I like how they did this so I
started doing some detective work and
this mod is taken from this mod that is
taking from this mod that I started
thinking they can dig it dig in and
found the first months of the game and
reverse google search them and trace
them back to like a couple of forum
posts posts so I searched that entire
forum thread and it went through like
the first post and started reading them
and it was a post about like the
performance of the game but halfway
through like post 300 or something
someone figured out how how they game
encrypted its files and created like a
set of commands that you could do to
unencrypt them and someone made a tool
about it and people started
experimenting a modding with it and I
remember finding this very specific post
of someone who went hey I unencrypted
the files I realized there's this folder
here which has a bunch of Lu a scripts
which are what the game runs every time
you change a graphical setting so and
this is often how games do it like when
you said shadows to low the game will
search up a script and it will be like
ok shadows to low means that this
resolution said to this this resolution
said to this and this draw distance is
said to this so they have this on
different pockets and I remember seeing
that and being like oh but now that I
have access to this file I can change
what that script does and I cooled
instead of lowering the resolution of
shadows I could make them not draw
shadows at all and I started doing this
sort of thing and created basically a
script that you could put in
replace the normal script of the game
and it will basically like not draw
shadows and use a lower resolution
texture than what he usually will do and
it will be immediately obvious why the
developer didn't do it because it really
screw up with the dynamic lighting
system of the game oh but it before it
was like a thirty five performance game
so yeah that was amazing I remember dude
I was so proud of that I'm putting a
video about it and someone else took
what I did in the video and created a
mod which was called like the potato
metal gear mod or something in
retrospective I wish I who could have
thought of that and I could have
published the mod instead of him but
yeah that was that was an interesting
contribution that I could do to that
community and and I was a very fun
process like vegan figuring out how to
unencrypt it and seeing all those files
there and play around with them that
done it that always makes my day so it
was really fun the Far Cry games run on
can't remember the name of the engine
they use but it's the same one for all
the Far Cry game it's just different
versions of the same engine and it has
configuration files that I read
everything in XML so I thought to myself
oh you can just probably find things
there and change them but it wouldn't
really read it anything and I could not
do like a really good video on several
or most of our games for a while so I
consulted with my discord community and
someone reminded me that I think Far Cry
3 or 4 has a decent modding community so
altogether we started looking through
the documentation of the modding
community it had a bunch of encrypted
configuration scripts that as most games
do execute when you setup and the
specific settings and people were
putting around with those so I started
trying to basically what I did with
Metal Gear and figured it out if I could
replace them and some very bold person
for my discord just decided to copy all
the variables from those hidden
encrypted configuration files copy and
paste them on the normal XM user
reachable XML and the game read them all
like the game read all the variables
that were not supposed to be on that
file perfectly flawlessly
and from that discovery we were able to
for example more dramatically modify the
draw distance of different elements of
the game so you will have enemies three
meters in front of you and they will not
be rendering and you can like it was
obviously very impractical but it was
something that you could play around
with for extra performance and from that
we made some interesting discoveries so
an LOD system in video games is
basically and I'm in a nutshell because
it's a very big topic is when you create
different versions of the models inside
games that have different quantities of
polygons or different quantities of
details and then with low detail ones
you display far off into the distance
and if that things gets close to you you
gradually replace them for more details
that way you can serve the PCs resources
and player doesn't really have to notice
that that is happening but those usually
are set to distances so X quantity of
pixels you load a different model double
X quantity of pixels you blow a
different model when you play around
with that interesting things happen for
example in the Far Cry games a few
different objects seem to be in
different pockets in terms of if they
are drawn or not or if the use of lower
version model or not I think higher
priority buckets or to run farther which
are critical things that the player
needs to notice and not so important
stuff tends to be not rendered at the
same distance now there's the game
called Far Cry primal which a happens
during the Stone Age we noticed that the
clothing of the caveman was in a
different pocket that the cavemen
themselves and that means that if you
set a really low value of your distance
if you were a certain distance from the
caveman they will be completely naked
until you get close to them and the
clothes will render so you will see them
completely naked at a distance and
we'll try to get clothes and the clothes
and the clothes will appear and it's a
makes you wonder how they sort of
created this game but those are the
interesting things that happen when you
sort of play around with the inside
variables of a game that you were not
supposed to reach in the first place and
to their credit these variables that the
far cry engine reads directly from the
user reachable XML they have not been
fixed to this day the last game in the
Far Cry franchise was released was for
cry nuan and they just copied over the
same set of variables that I've been
using forever before cry video work at
the first try so thank you for that far
cry team thank you yourself please
continue doing that that is just very
very fun that you can poke around in
that eighty ninety percent of the work
that I do is simply figuring out what
are the variables that the game is
loading when you set up a graphical
setting or when the engine is loading on
the first time trying to see where the
names try to see where the maximum and
minimum values and trying to see if you
can make them breathe and the main
values and see what happens from there
it would be I think will be healthier
for the entire PC gaming ecosystem if we
get more and more games that allow that
sort of control over most particles a
good example of someone who does that is
it so the new newest versions of the eat
engine used by the latest doom and
Wolfenstein games they have an user
which able developer console it's you
set over a variable and the lunch
comments of the game and you press tilde
and it opens up in most games and from
there you can not only play with a lot
of the graphical settings but also
activate things like god mode or
infinite ammo like you can use it for
actual cheats but what I have always
liked about this games is that if you
open up the dev console and you type
anything you get a message that says you
have enabled dev mode and you will not
get any achievements on the game like
and I think that's a fair deal you can
play around with the game all you want
you can
a custom settings you can play around
with your graphical settings in no
supported ways the game is just making
sure you're not cheating your way into
achievements seems like a fair deal to
me and I and I wish more games that this
because this is something that you can
all other players can get a lot of
benefit out of and III have discovered a
couple of things on the on that that
console that makes both the new doom and
the new Wolfenstein games way more
accessible and low-end pcs so that is a
tradition that I that I hope it
continues the worst cases are the games
that are complete just bad ports from
consoles they will try to grab the code
base from the console and slight adapted
as best as possible with limited
resources to PC that means not many
graphical settings that means often that
you will find quirks there's two two
examples come to mind
near automata and the latest Monster
Hunter game both of this games and this
is not me saying it this is that was a
community discovery what are people
started poking around the games and
started realizing that the games use
timing systems that are very common for
consoles but when you use that sort of
system to calculate your timing on a PC
it causes stuttering and so when you
notice stuff like that you're like it's
a little bit irritating especially
because there's a tool that the guy who
did the discovery developed a tool that
will in real time intersect the calls
that the game will be doing on the code
and replaced them with calls that were
more efficient for PC and he has been he
added a lot of different things to this
tool that improved it improved the CPU
performance of monster hunter by a lot
and that allow things like changing the
global illumination for Nier automata
which completely makes the game playable
in like anything that I owned otherwise
it would have been impossible
so for
time to time the work is caught out to
me by someone else who make this
marvelous pieces of software but these
pieces of software sort of exist because
someone noticed that the code was
written specifically for consul and he
still has two quirks related to it and
it's all been to the community to fix it
which isn't exactly morally right but at
least I'm glad that it exists so we can
get to enjoy this games right these are
the kind of things that people who are
writing computer games not me people who
know what they're doing writing computer
games are thinking about right how can
we do post-processing like motion blur
and bloom and other kinds of filters
that look good in a game but don't grind
a whole thing to a